bonjour je m'appelle Pierre lescur et je
vais être amené à commenter un certain
nombre d'archives de
Lina bonjour Pierre lescur bonjour Alors
pierre lescur vous êtes un amoureux du
cinéma de la télévision des stars de la
culture de la musique des objets j'ai
oublié une de vos passions euh le sport
c'est vrai le sport votre histoire c'est
aussi celle des médias que vous avez
contribuer à développer et même à
révolutionner disons-le et que nous
allons parcourir en archive et pour
commencer Federico Fellini écoutons
l'immense réalisateur italien parler de
la télévision dans l'émission cinéma
cinéma sur Antenne 2 c'était en
1986 non dico responsabile ma fatalmente
certo la televisione ha creato un
rapporto diverso tra lo spettatore e
l'immagine non è più quel rapporto così
intimidito
suggestionato
fiducioso estato che il grande schermo
che chiamava raccolta come in una chies
pubblico poi si spegneva la luce si
illuminava questo enorme lenzuolo gli
attori erano enormi con questi gran
faccioni labroni poi si vedevano posti
misteriosi tutto l'aspetto esotico tutto
questo la televisione l'ha
irremediabilmente distrutto cancellato
insomma è un'immagine completamente
diversa è un'immagine schizofrenica
psichedelica nevrotica coriandolizzata
frantumizzata è una specie di
calidoscopio di sollettico all'occhio
che a lungo andare dopo tanto tempo ha
creato un tipo di spettatore impaziente
superficiale che pretende di far lui il
film cambiando
continuamentemagine
program c'est magnifique parce que Fedic
fini donne en creux une définition une
illustration de son amour du cinéma le
cinéma c'est une évasion comme tous les
autres arts qu'on pourrait évoquer
depuis la regarde qui plaisante avec le
leur tigas et leurs cheveux plus ou
moins mointain comme ce de Marcello
c'est à tomber Edgar Morin en 68 il a
sorti un petit bouquin qu'on trouve
encore en poche qui s'appelle star et
Edgar Morin définissait ce qu'est une
star la star c'est la distance donc on
on on regarde les vedettes du cinéma en
particulier comme des comme des étoiles
c'est le contraire de la quotidienneté
la télé c'est tous les jours et chez
vous il y a pas plus vulgaire au sens
latin du terme donc quand on me dit la
star du Trésor
c'est pathétique faut trouver un autre
mot il est star parce qu'il est là tous
les jours donc c'est pas une star donc
c'est tout l'inverse du rêve et de la
réalité quotidienne alors en parlant de
la télévision et du cinéma vous avez
évoqué le rapport et la distance par
rapport au star écoutez l'une des plus
grandes d'entre elles en 1973 dans
l'émission grand écran Catherine est-ce
que d'abord vous acceptez l'étiquette de
star en
fait
étiquette non ni l'étiquette ni le mot
donc non j'accepte pas beaucoup c'est
d'ailleurs un mot très discuté en France
en fait mais d'abord c'est pas un mot
français c'est juste et ensuite c'est ni
par fausse modestie ni par ni par
orgueil mais je trouve que ce me me
convient pas
tellement néanmoins votre statut a
changé dans le courant de votre carrière
vous êtes devenu quelqu'un sur laquel on
peut tout de même bâtir un film
entièrement sur votre nom ah oui mais il
y a beaucoup d'acteurs je veux dire qui
ont cette chance quand même je cro il y
en a quelquesuns il y en a pas tellement
non quand on dit quand on dit star en
tous les cas en France avec le l'auréool
qu'on toujours les les acteurs
américains puisque c'est un mot
américain vraiment américain plus
qu'anglais même il y a l'idée d'une
d'une personne à qui on pardonne tout je
crois qu'elle soit bonne ou mauvaise et
qu'elle est fait des erreurs des bons
films qu'elle est emmerdé des
producteurs ou qu'elle est gâché des des
choses pendant un film c'est quelqu'un
qui malgré tout éclate dans un film et à
qui on pardonne tout je crois elle a
raison elle n'est pas au sens américain
du terme des années 40 50 60 une star
elle est pour la France et l'Europe
comme d'autres grande figure féminine du
du cinéma européen mais par exemple
Catherine denuve depuis ses 18 ans a
jalousement défendu sa sa vie privée
elle a gagné tous les procès qu'elle a
fait dès lors qu'on parlait de sa vie
privée ou qu'on l'illustrait et et je
signale en passant que tout ce qu'elle
gagnait dans ses procès puisqu'elle a
gagné ça FA jurisprudence tout le blé
qu'elle a gagné le filet Amnesty
internationale et continue des gens
comme Delon ou belmondeo qui sont les
dernières grande star masculine
française on les voyait très peu à la
télé on voyait un à deux films par an et
on les voyait une fois au 20H une fois
dans une émission du dimanche après-midi
Point Bar on les voyait pas tout le
temps tout partout aussi bien c'est à
vous que que sur tous les les plateaux
télé et et à forcierie les réseaux
est-ce que est-ce que les stars existent
encore je pense que les stars n'existent
plus mais il y a des personnages
auxquels on aime s'identifier parce
qu'ils sont d'abord comédien ou
comédiens et qu'on devine ou qu'on sait
que dans leur vie quotidienne ils sont
citoyens ou citoyens ça veut pas dire
signer de la de la pétition au rouleau
ça veut dire qu'ils ont des
engagement qui ne font pas de doute une
fois par an le repère des stars c'est le
festival de Can vous en avez été le
président pendant 8 ans écoutez ce qu'en
disait Michel odudiar en 1964 en son
temps le traité de vesfaliie a eu une
utilité on a un peu oublié laquelle et
je crois que le festival de Cann c'est
le même cas ça a correspondu à quelque
chose il y a à sa création et puis
maintenant c'est du une sorte de foire
amusante d'ailleurs si elle se passait
liéard il y aurait personne à can c'est
agréable autant vous êtes là mais je
suis là parce que j'ai d'ord par
correction pour mes interprètes pour mon
metteur en scène et puis c'est c'est de
la balade après je vais aller jouer au
bou à saint-pau de VCE moi je me marre
ici nous on a sorti 100000 dollars au
soleil il y a il y a une semaine on a
fait 90000 entrées la première semaine
qu'est-ce que voulez que ça me foute que
12 personnes de plus enfermé dans une
chambre décrête que ce film est bon ou
mauvais ça m' diffère totalement et ben
fallait pas venir mon gars je pense que
le traité de vesphali il est un peu
dépassé il a raison le Michel mais en
même temps regardez l'année dernière le
Festival de Cannes les 12 personnes
enfermées dans une dans une pièce pour
discuter des films euh ils ont désigné
anatomie d'une chute le monde entier et
singulièrement les anglossaxon sont en
train de considérer que c'est sans doute
l'une des meilleures réalisations l'un
des meilleurs scénarios l'une des
meilleures interprète avec Sandra huller
et en même temps globalement l'un des
meilleurs films d'une tout finalement
jeune réalisatrice française cette
reconnaissance qui a été aussi celle du
public et d'une grande partie de la
critique elle s'est symbolisé à Cannes à
la fin des des césares et des Oscars de
l'année suivante vous regardez les
entrées en salle vous regardez la liste
des Oscars et des et des et des Césars
et 9,9 fois sur 10 vous vous dites à can
ils sont pas trop gourés pierre les vous
êtes français mais vous avez réussi
l'exploit je suis français monsieur oui
tout à fait mais vous avez réussi
l'exploit de conquérir Hollywood lorsque
vous étiez directeur de vivendy
Universal on écoute le témoignage de
célèbres expatriés Michel Morgan
Jean-Pierre Aumont et agès Varda sur la
vie nocturne de cette ville mythique en
1973 je me disais qu'un jour j'aimerais
si je devenais
actrice devenir une grande star
internationale et j'ai découvert la
Californie j'ai découvert Hollywood j'ai
découvert les la maison de Rudolf
Valentino j'ai rencontré les star
c'était quelque chose d'extraordinaire
al le samedi soir on donnait d'immenses
soirées il s'appelaient des parties avec
trois orchestres des tentes dressé dans
des parcs avec des éclairages savants et
cetera et alors là tout le monde se
salait et tout le monde dansait jusqu'à
l'aube ces gensl font des parties où il
y a 100 personnes et et il y a pas une
personne qui ne soit pas connue mais
très connue comprz nous on a rarement
été invité mais quand on est invité bon
je sais pas une dizaine de fois dans des
endroits comme ça c'était fabuleux vous
comprenez c'était la veuve de selsnick
et vous rencontriez Rita hew et tout ça
et c'est moi pour moi c'est gênant vous
savez d'être à table comme ça avec tous
ces gens si connus ben j'ai été invité
oui bien sûr j'étais patron de
d'Universal patron non exécutif et
j'étais l'autorité morale et juridique
puisque vivindi était devenu
propriétaire de d'Universal au moment de
la fusion Universal canal plus vivindi
mon bureau était dans la black Tower qui
est la la le bureau directorial la tour
de 16 étages dans Universal City à côté
du champ des des plateaux de tournage et
et des décors un peu comme le montre
votre archive à l'instant et de mon
bureau on apercevait l'attraction du
parc Universal où où il y a les
pérodacyes donc vous avez votre
interlocuteur comme je vous ai en ce
moment et puis en même temps vous avez
le pérodacctyle qui monte et qui descend
donc c'était déjà un autre monde et puis
quand vous alleiez à la fenêtre vous
saviez que sous les sous les les toits
arrondis des des 15 studios des 15
plateaux de tournage il y avait des
films qui étaaient en train de se
fabriquer et est-ce que c'est pas un
rêve de gosse un peu inattendu venant
d'un enfant d'une famille communiste non
parce que vous avez une vision
extrêmement étroite du communisme j'ai
eu le le bol fou vous avez raison de
vivre dans une famille extrêmement
ouverte où il y avait des communistes
comme mon père qui était rédacteur en
chef àuma mais il y avait des gens qui
étaient de gauche mais sans aucun
sectarisme donc c'est une ouverture
d'esprit qui faisait que mon père quand
j'étais gamin et et ma mère et toute ma
famille aussi me montrait combien
l'Amérique était était un pays complexe
puisqu'il y avait la ségrégation euh il
y avait la dureté des temps de
l'Amérique ultra libérale mais il y
avait aussi la littérature américaine la
musique américaine le cinéma américain
on a toujours privilégié la culture d'où
qu'ell viennent bien avant Hollywood et
les stars vous vous êtes intéressé aux
journaux on va écouter parler le
fondateur d'un de vos magazines préférés
depuis l'adolescence c'était sur l'ORTF
en 1971 monsieur Playboy en est persuadé
l'Amérique comme le monde entier connaît
actuellement une révolution sexuelle
Playboy a fait beaucoup dans le sens de
cette révolution dit-il les Français et
bien ils ont toujours eu la réputation
d'être romantiques et d'être également
très proches des questions
sexuelles ouvrir un club Playboy à Paris
et bien nous étudions la question ainsi
que celle d'un casino en france bientôt
une édition française de Playboy sortira
enfin les critères de choix pour devenir
bonise avoir de la personnalité et de la
beauté il y avait chez chez hugfner euh
une marchandisation une objétisation euh
de de la femme euh c'est pas seulement
parce que les temps ont changé euh on se
dit qu'il y avait quelque chose de de
réducteur beaucoup plus que que
libérateur c'est une évidence et je le
pensais déjà à l'époque en revanche ce
qui me fascinait c'était de voir euh
pour la première fois ce mariage entre
des des entretiens vachement
intéressants je me souviens d'une des
plus belles interviews de Pierre Singer
qui était le un des principaux
collaborateurs de John Kennedy une de
ces interviews les plus intéressantes
pour le journaliste que j'étais c'était
dans Playboy c'était une une
cohabitation étonnante et ce constat que
vous que vous appliquez aux femmes dans
dans Playboy les femmes objets est-ce
que est-ce que ce constat est le même
selon vous pour les pinup dont vous êtes
fan sur les pinup dans les années 50 et
les années 40 50 il y avait quelque
chose qui était toujours grâce au code a
qui était un code de
moralité américain très très pudibon
très conservateur et salement
conservateur c'est la même époque que le
mcartisme il y avait énormément d'humour
et et vous avez des illustrateurs de de
d'immense qualité des gens comme ELV
graen yor Moran ou encore plus Enoc
balls dans les années 30 40 qui ont
donné à la fois une fraîcheur une
certaine noblesse délicate et beaucoup
d'humour à tous ces toutes ces
représentations de la femme c'est ces
pinoplque avec Alain Degreff on a voulu
présenter dans canal où il y avait la
pinup du jour de manière souriante et et
élégante depuis l'enfance vous êtes un
amoureux de la télévision et très jeune
vous aviez déjà une idée très précise de
ce à quoi devait ressembler écoutez vous
parler dans l'émission Âge tendre et
tête de bois en
1976 vous aviez 19
ans vient de nous chter un standard
c'est un succès qu'ont déjà freudonné
nos aînés et bien justement on écoutant
HH tendre en suivant l'émission nous
trouvons qu'elle fait la part un peu
trop belle au Dan et à la chanson c'est
pourquoi nous aimerion trouver aussi une
sorte de cinq colonnes pour les jeunes
qui pourrait être en liaison avec des
des émissions telles que sport jeunesse
ou le monde en 40 minutes et ben le le
garçon s'y voyait déjà le voilà qui a 19
ans donne des leçons je pense que
c'était assez ambitieux pour les jeunes
on peut aimer l' yer on peut avoir envie
de jouer au au flipper ou au Baby fooot
de twister ou de rocker et en même temps
de s'intéresser être aussi concerné par
la guerre au Vietnam ou la
décolonisation et d'ailleurs vous avez
aussi présenté le journal télévisé j'ai
toujours eu du goût pour les cravates
vous avez remarqué
euh un goût assez tranché et dont
j'aurais pu me passer j'ai présenté le
journal de 20H j'étais le le le petit 4e
à l'époque d'un quitueur où il y avait
Jean-Pierre l Cabache Jean-Marie Cavada
mon ami et mon frère Jean-Michel
desjeunes qui est parti trop tôt et ma
pomme qui était le 4e du quituor et
c'était une bonne expérience pour vous
c'était une bonne expérience et en même
temps j'en ai vu à titre très personnel
la limite j'ai un regard qui est assez
efficace si on me cadre de près en
revanche si on commençait à élargir le
champ pour placer d'autres images à côté
de moi ce qui se faisait de plus en plus
et ce qui s'est fait de plus en plus je
trouvais que j'étais moins efficace dans
ma manière de capter l'attention et je
me suis dit que c'est sans doute pas là
que j'avais intérêt à creuser mon chemin
si je voulais trouver des aventures
excitantes et m'épanouir et me
développer donc j'ai
abandonné la présentation au bout de 2
ans c'est qui pour vous le meilleur
présentateur ou la meilleure
présentatrice de tous les temps
Christine ocrent a montré dans les
années 80 parce qu'elle était la
première femme qui alliait une séduction
à l'image qui qui vous prenait hommes ou
femmes d'un seul coup on était attiré
par ce visage et par l'intensité du
regard et une grande rigueur de texte et
et de propos je trouve que les choses se
sont beaucoup banalisées les lancements
de sujets
sont devenus des textes où on cite tout
le monde toutes les équipes de tournage
on trouve des phrases passe partout pour
passer de d'une catastrophe au Pakistan
à à la météo à perosgerc et tout ça est
devenu très inintéressant en revanche
les les présentatrices de d'émission de
plateau toutes les descendantes d'Anne
Saint-Clair me semble beaucoup plus
intéressante pierre lescur vous êtes fan
de cinéma de pinup mais vous aimez aussi
la musique et on va écouter un de vos
chanteurs préférés Johnny Chan une
chanson d'un autre de vos chanteurs
préférés Elvis prley ça se passe dans
l'émission les 1200 coups en
1966 plus que n'importe
quoi avant mes débuts même depuis très
longtemps depuis plus de 10 ans et j'ai
à cause de cette
[Musique]
chanson j'ai besoin de silence un peu de
silence s'il vous plaît vous êtes très
gentil merci c'est une chanson qui a
besoin de beaucoup d'attention bon
nousécoutons avec beaucoup
d'attention je trouve qu' très jolie
Paro pour les personnes qui comprennent
l'anglais
[Musique]
évidemment
elle est magnifique votre archive elle
est magnifique parce que
le il y a aucune il y en a rarement eu
chez lui mais là il y a vraiment zéro
affectation il est seul avec sa guitare
il prend l'une des chansons les plus
simples les plus profondes et les plus
absolu prle
et et le fait que Johnny demande le
silence je trouve ça magnifique parce
que pour lui c'est profond c'est un truc
important il a envie de le faire bien
donc il il a envie que ce soit bien
écouté donc il demande le silence je
trouve ça absolument
[Musique]
magnifique ça représente quoi le rock
and roll pour vous bah je suis de cette
génération pour qui le rock and roll a
tout changé prley dans les années au
milieu des années 50 c'est une explosion
de musique cet homme mine de rien euh
vit dans une petite ville du sud des
États-Unis où la ségrégation euh règne
et pourtant lui va écouter euh les Noirs
américains dans les les faubourgs de
Memphis et de Tupelo au Mississippi et
d'un seul coup il voit bien que c'est
cette musique là qui lui plaît il va
l'acclimater pour les d'ailleurs ça lui
sera proché par les conservateurs
américains au départ alors on voit les
jeunes filles qui crient mais
musicalement il va révolutionner la
musique et ouvrir un champ que
reprendront ensuite tous les Anglais des
Beatles et des Stones donc c'est
révolutionnaire le rock and roll c'est
devenue une musique classique mais ça a
révolutionné 40 ans de musique avec les
enfants du rock vous avez fait entrer à
la télévision française sur le service
public toutes les musiques du moment à
l'époque le rock le punk le hard rock
cela n'existe plus nulle part
aujourd'hui alors on va se réécouter un
peu du du générique des enfants du rock
pour le
[Musique]
plaisir c'est magnifique parce que
Pierre desgrope qui était le patron
d'Antenne 2 à l'époque m'a fait venir en
me proposant de de faire des émissions
pour les jeunes et on a voulu avec Alain
Degreff que j'ai rencontré mon fidèle
compagnon avec lequel j'ai j'ai bâti
canal ensuite on a voulu faire une
émission qui soit une planète de musique
qui soit pas juste des concerts donc il
y avait à la fois de la BD il y avait de
la vidéo il y avait de l'humour il y
avait des concerts il y avait des
interviews et et on essayait que ce soit
une planète je pense que c'est ce qui a
fait son succès et que c'est resté le 4
novembre 1984 un séisme secoue la
télévision française l'arrivée de Canal
Plus dont vous avez été le chef
d'orchestre en France ce matin bonjour
canal plus la petite sœur privée et la
bienvenue quelques seconde avant 8h la
première émission a commencé avec ce que
cela comporte d'émotion et puis de
balbuement toute cette journée vous avez
pu si vous possédez un décodeur si vous
faites partie des régions concernées
suivre les premières heures de Canal
Plus et tous ces invités après ce
générique je ne suis évidemment pas là
pour en faire la publicité mais la
pluralité est une bonne chose et la
concurrence aussi alors cet événement
méritait bien d'être salué et méritait
aussi je crois quel qu
explications le soir de ce 4 novembre 84
Claude Cillon a a eu en direct André
Rousselet qui était le fondateur de de
Canal Plus et qui m'avait appelé à ses
côtés pour pour m'occuper des programmes
et et Claude sirillon a dit à André
Rousselet c'est magnifique cette
première journée en même temps vous êtes
conscient André Rous ça ne peut pas
marcher on peut pas faire payer la
télévision vous êtes conscient que ça ne
marchera pas on savait que pour la
première fois ça c'était révolutionnaire
on faisait payer la télévision il
fallait donc qu'il y ait un sentiment
chez vous client potentiel quel que soit
votre âge ou votre porte-monnaie il
fallait que l'évidence de quelque chose
de neuf qui pouvait se payer en plus de
la revance soit manifeste donc on avait
une blanche on a essayé de la faire la
plus novatrice possible c'était pas la
course sffrainé au buzz ou à il faut
faire un truc qu'on a jamais fait mais
on a essayé de de mettre tout ce qu'on
avait pas vu à la télé et qu'on avait
envie d'y voir et de donner leur chance
à des à des talents qu'on avait pas vu à
la télévision je pense que c'est
l'addition de tout ça mais c'est surtout
la page blanche canal plus c'est la page
blanche mais c'est aussi un vent de
fraîcheur de liberté qui commence à
souffler c'est le moment de voir un des
sketch des marionnettes les plus
célèbres de l'histoire du
PAF la nuit des guignoles j'ai adoré oui
grosse
satisfaction roi du pétrole c'est notre
ton ça notre ton l'insolence c'est canal
ça c'est canal impertinence insolence
l'impertinence c'est une grosse
satisfaction Votre action n'a jamais été
aussi haute mais ouais c'est dingue avec
le foot l'impertinence c'est ce qu'on a
de
mieux cul et cul oui cul oui qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour être encore
plus insolent impertinent ah du cul à
20h30 ouais
ou les infos par Jamel en langage
banlieu genre ta mère tout ça il a déjà
pensé Laurent Gérard il est impertinent
pas sûr il d couill ah faut provoquer
osz tout marche ça voilà rentrez dedans
c'est toujours payant pour faire des
trucs dingues tout oser avoir peur de
rien insolent tout le temps les gens
adorent ça c'est quoi le truc le plus
insolent qu'on pourrait faire ah
dirageent à se désabonn de Canal
Plus même pour rire tu déconnes jamais
avec le
stock c'est pas beau ça c'est magnifique
c'est fascinant de regarder ça avec les
yeux d'aujourd'hui de se dire que des
salariés en direct à l'antenne pouvait
se moquer des patrons de leur propre
chaîne et pourtant je vous assure que ça
me semblait être et ça me semble
toujours être la moindre des choses la
télévision c'est quand même quelque
chose de quotidien c'est quelque chose
qui vient chez les gens tous les jours
et du matin au soir et et plus que
jamais aujourd'hui si ça ne sait pas ne
pas se prendre au sérieux le verre est
dans le fruit moi je suis frappé
aujourd'hui de voir que la plupart des
médias sont dirigés par des gens qui ne
viennent pas du contenu qui sont de des
gens qui ont beaucoup de goût pour les
contenus mais qui sont avant tout des
commerciaux des juristes des financiers
des technocrates souvent dans le
meilleur des cas ils ont fait Science Po
dans la plupart ont fait des écoles
commerciales ou des les écoles de de
technocrate mais il y a peu de gens de
contenu alors que toutes vos archives
démontrent depuis les origines de la
télé jusqu'à aujourd'hui que les plus
grandes aventures celles qui restent
dans la mémoire des gens celles qui ont
fait gagner le plus d'argent sont des
aventures où les femmes et les hommes
qui étaient à leur tête étaient des gens
de contenu c'est un métier le contenu
qu'est-ce qu'on vend on vend du contenu
donc le métier principal c'est le
contenu c'est pas le commerce c'est n
pas la finance c'est une erreur de ne
pas privilégier à la tête des grands
médias aujourd'hui et des boîtes de
contenus de ne pas mettre que des gens
de contenu à la tête de Canal plus
aujourd'hui on a Vincent Boloré
actionnaire majoritaire de vivendy à la
tête du conseil de surveillance de sa
filiale canal plus nous allons écouter
son discours aux employés de la chaîne
lors de son arrivée en 2016 c'est vrai
que quand je lis les
articles j'ai l'impression de le
retrouver dans une série télé à un peu
moyenne où il y a un psychopathe qui est
arrivé dans une pension de famille
psychopathe c'est moi la pension de
famille c'est vous et le psychopathe
sans savoir exactement pourquoi ou qui
tue régulièrement brutalement un certain
nombre de gens et souvent du rire et de
l'argent l'actionnaire promet d'investir
2 milliards d'euros vraiment rassurant
en tout cas un grand un grand orateur
c'était de la bombe mec c la c'est le
meilleur standup que j'ai vu de ma vie
ça pourrait paraître un peu superficiel
mais lui il a de la méthode et
on sent que c'est c'est nourri de de
quelque chose tout ce qu'il dit vous
savez vous avez un patron qui arrive qui
dit je vais remettre de l'argent je vais
développer la boîte à 80 % ça séduit les
salariés c'est compréhensible nous on a
un petit problème en terme de
journalisme c'est que l'information est
Borée apparemment ça fait deux pour le
reste il peut faire une chaîne avec une
information manipulée ou censurée je
veux dire ou pas en faire du tout il
aura quand même une chaîne de télé hein
bah tout été dit Vincent Boloré en tant
que financier est sans doute un des des
plus efficaces des plus intelligents des
plus tenaces et des plus successful à la
fin de de 2023 le le monde a sorti une
enquête extrêmement fouillé qui
racontait comment d'opération
financière en opération financière
successive Boloré a a tiré le maximum
pour la holding et les actionnaires de
profit financiers est-ce qu'il y a eu un
maximum d'investissement pour développer
la valeur des boîtes je n'en suis pas sû
puisqu'il est quasiment il a tiré tout
le jus financier d'Universal musique et
il en est sorti il n'en est plus
aujourd'hui le le
principal opérateur canal continue
d'être sa propriété mais avant tout sa
seule créativité aura été financière
c'est mon point de vue dans 10 ans d'ici
la famille Bolloré sera très riche je
voudrais bien savoir ce qu'il restera
des marques et moi personnellement je
reste abonné à Canal plus parce que la
politique de de du directeur général
Maxime Saada fait que les accords qu'il
a passés aussi bien avec Disney plus
qu'avec Netflix et bein plus les
programmes de Canal et des chaînes
adjacentes fait que vous avez le bouquet
où il y a le plus de choses vous auriez
pu embaucher Cyril Hanouna à Canal plus
le personnage d'anuna du début seul ou
avec Jean-Pierre foucot sur RTL c'est un
garçon qui avait un talent qui l'utilise
maintenant autrement euh et et de
manière plus plus empirique je ne pense
pas qu'on l'aurait que que de Greff
l'aurait ou moi l'auriion signé à canal
sous cette forme là mais mais au départ
c'était un un amoureux de de choses
assez voisines des nôtres il y a une
passion que nous n'avons pas encore
évoqué ensemble mais qui vous colle
encore à la peau on écoute George Perrec
parler de la beauté des
objets nous vivons dans un monde qui est
beau qui nous parle d'une manière très
forte la beauté d'une voiture ou d'un
meuble nous sentons tout de suite
qu'elle contient beaucoup plus de choses
que la simple beauté il nous semble
qu'elle détient une sorte de secret
qu'elle nous offre un véritable art de
vivre que tout ce qui nous est donné à
voir c'est beaucoup plus de choses que
la beauté c'est de l'argent c'est du
confort c'est du bonheur c'est presque
une certaine forme d'idéal les voitures
luisantes les meubles étinselants des
espaces immenses et clair avec les
moquettes le monde dans lequel nous
vivons le monde que nous rencontrons
chaque fois que nous sortons dans la rue
chaque fois nous entrons dans les
magasins est un monde riche fascinant et
beau l'ennui c'est que nous pouvons voir
mais nous n'avons pas le droit de
toucher parce qu'en fait nous ne vivons
pas dans ces meubles nous ne conduisons
pas ces voitures nous ne mangeons pas du
foie gras et du homard à nos repas nous
ne vivons pas dans les espaces clairs
couverts de moquettes dans les années 40
50 et 60 il y a quand même eu une une
libéralisation au meilleur sens du
terme une ouverture à presque tout
toutes les bourses de design et de et et
et de conception et de créativité des
objets y compris des objets du quotidien
même si vous achetiez chip parce que
votre votre vos revenus et votre budget
personnel était très modeste il y avait
pas de raison qu'on vous vende de
l'utilitaire qui ne soit pas aussi beau
d'où la création du design industriel de
tout ce qui pouvait faire qu'un objet
même du quotidien même ne volant volant
3 franc 6 sous il y a pas de raison que
ce soit pas beau et j'ai cette cette
passion pour les tout ce qui a été créé
dans ces années où on essayait de faire
que le beau soit partout bah là on me
voit au milieu d'objets que j'ai été
amené à
vendre regardez cette regardez ce poste
de radio c'est dément c'est un sparton
c'est une radio de 1932 en glace bleue
avec des des lignes Art Déco magnifique
ça c'est une pin une pinup d'elfve
graine Jean-Pierre Baker adorit cette
pinup il m'avait dit tu es trop con de
la vendre mais j'étais obligé et ça vous
a déchiré le cœur de dev voir vendre
toute cette collection sur le coup oui
mais j'étais enfin déchirer le cœur il y
a plus grave dans la vie mais j'étais
obligé de vendre parce que j'ai été viré
dans des conditions qui faisaient que je
j'étais obligé de de faire face à des
une difficultés
financière radicale mais Daniel
philiipaki qui a été un grand patron de
presse et un grand photographe m'avait
dit tu verras tu te rends pas compte tu
as accumulé des tas de chos
mais tu vas voir que quand tu vas faire
ta vente tu vas te rendre compte que
sans doute il y a une cohérence qui
raconte quelque chose de ta vie et de ce
que tu as aimé dans la vie et tu en
seras un peu fier avec un petit F et il
avait raison Daniel
philiipaki on me voit là quand je me
balade au milieu de de l'exposition
avant avant la vente j'ai sans doute un
peu de mélancolie mais en même temps je
je me dis que ça raconte une histoire y
compris les les illustration les les
tableaux d'illustrateurs que j'ai pu euh
que j'ai pu acheter ou même toutes ces
histoires de post de radio que j'avais
en en quantité industrielle c'est
désormais le moment pour moi d'arrêter
de vous poser des questions et pour vous
de choisir qui va vous poser la
prochaine entre Christine Bravo Jérôme
Garsin Henry Chapier et Anne Saintclair
euh j'ai envie d'écouter Anne Saintclair
qu'est-ce qui vous reste maintenant à à
justement à rêver à vouloir à qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui reste c'est en
permanence travailler en équipe avoir à
la fois des vieux bonses comme
moi mais qui gardent de la fantaisie et
de la gourmandise et d'avoir à côté des
jeunes gens qui m'épattent et ce sont
des jeunes gens et des jeunes femmes qui
bouinent qui vont au cinéma qui donc me
rafraîchissent me nourrissent de trucs
neufs me font en même temps raconter des
histoires comme l'oncle Paul dans ce
spirirou quand j'étais gamin et et en
permanence dans les boî de contenu
qu'elle soit de télévision de journaux
de podcast de cinéma ou de musique il
faut cette espèce d'alliance entre la la
mémoire qui ne vous a pas coupé la
gourmandise et la jeunesse qui vous
nourrit et c'est comme ça que naissent
les les choses nouvelles et les choses
qui éventuellement vont créer de
nouvelles archives merci Pierre lescur
merci à
[Musique]
vous